welcome to this video playing mini tour
from the u.s. to the name in them no
okay let's see I had a good time win
recently with those with this exchange
against them with h3h3 e5 exchange now
okay yeah let's not align that people
are tied to know too well Black has some
more than one idea to to equalize this
is one of them there's a long class old
song I think tend to forget this this
line
yeah this is some a very solid wave
would like to answer the exchange of
course the exchange itself as some it's
not the most exciting opening ever but
of all the lines that black can play he
chose them the most solid one but maybe
I have a slight slight something here my
ideas Bishop c5 that would actually
provoke him almost force him to exchange
so he needs to UM he needs to react to
this idea i think i think at least maybe
bishop to f8 as an idea to one to defend
has one yeppa Bishop c5 what are you
playing on that don't know Oh is he
sacrificing upon him I just say what he
just wants to play b6 I see yeah it's
not bad okay I save should I go to a
three here probably this doesn't object
or Bishop d6 maybe yeah it probably
doesn't matter anyway this is equal
yeah here I mean okay it's still equal
but um I at least I have some sleight
hopes that I maybe can do something on
the queenside he still has got the
slightly worse Bishop from a structural
point of view I mean the shop here less
visible as I to Knight to c6 me know
this is this is completely idiotic not
to see seven on a three stone oak oh
here he can probably have play just 96
and a six and term and draw
hmm ok ok maybe he wants to play a
neither form I can't need to react to
that so winning its temple maybe yeah
before b5 this I get this end this is
the system but they're just blogged on
the bishop can't believe that it is
trapped God ok mmm yeah it's pretty
difficult to lose in this opening but
you can manage ok my 97 now would have
been even more precise but ok this this
is of course enough ah Jesus well i came
i just want to see if i get both pawns
but i don't think so he can just
approach with the king
hmm yeah it was a draw problem and hard
to imagine that I should should have had
if any advantage I don't understand the
what he is doing I can I can give this
check okay i see but still was this the
most precise side that i really don't
think so i take a 5v5 can be 786 he's
not even stopping this land
this is him the only only winning idea I
mean know that that's enough hmm
no like a dress on and just packing you
six okay yeah this is a really cool way
to 22 he's writing to me why I don't see
I'm sure what hey what is talking about
i'm just a piece down he plays f5 and
wins
no yeah I just trapped my own Bishop
here thank you otherwise that I think
it's just the draw thanks for watching